the pearl et la structure ultra haute la
plus sophistiqués au monde
mais revenez au paradis monsieur hire wa
que ça brûle
attendez ma famille est à l'intérieur
cette tour protège quelque chose que je
veux en ce moment la seule chose qui
compte c'est ma famille
tous les hommes ou une faiblesse de
faiblesse va pas et monsieur papa m qui
s'est à famille tu va m'apporter quelque
chose que je
[Musique]
le 96e est en feu
on doit sortir de cette tour papa et
mocky mois
the pearl et la structure n'a plus
sophistiqués au monde mais c'est
difficile de prévoir ce qui arriverait
en cas de problème antunez ma famille
est à l'intérieur
vous arrêtez pas pour tourner pas
je vous retrouverai
et
ça me manque ça fait dix ans que j'ai
pas touché une arme après ce qui s'est
passé cette nuit là j'ai comme qui
dirait rengainer - colt mais sans ce
coup du sort vous allez vous en sortir
je n'aurais jamais connu ça j'aurais
jamais eu mes enfants papa m qui n'a pas
ému qui jetait monsieur hire vous êtes
la toute première famille que nous
accueillons dans la partie résidentielle
deux perles à l'issue de votre audit de
sécurité
que pensez vous de la tour de pearl et
la structure ultra haute la plus
sophistiqués au monde
c'est une prouesse technologique mais
c'est difficile de prévoir ce qui
arriverait en cas de problème
[Musique]
salut les gars
que symbole le 96e est en feu sarah
écoute moi le feu va progresser vous
devez monter ne vous arrêtez pas ne vous
retournez pas ok reculées où on
attendait ma famille est à l'intérieur
tournez-vous
surtout regarde pas en bas
c'était pas mal hein
là
tout à fait contraire je me suis jetée
d'une craie
voilà l'homme que nous cherchions cette
tour droite est quelque chose que je
et tu va me rapporter rien n'est
impossible quand on est motivé
non
ensemble on dira j'ai peur
c'est normal d'avoir peur
pour être courageux avant il faut avoir
un petit peu peur
on doit sortir de cette tour tu veux
bien être courageux pour moi papa aime
qui mois
[Musique]
tous